♪
>>> THIS WEEK OUR "SPRING INTO
SUMMER" SERIES LOOKS AT WHAT YOU
CAN EXPECT WHEN YOU MAKE SUMMER
PLANS AS LIFE BEGINS TO RETURN
TO NORMAL.
FOR SOME, THAT MEANS BRINGING
BACK THE THRILLS.
AND WE SENT MEG OL LAIVER TO NE
JERSEY WHERE SHE HOPPED ON A
ROLLER COASTER, MET SOME
ELEPHANTS AND FOUND SOMETHING
FUN FOR EVERYONE.
>> Reporter: THIS SUMMER, MANY
FAMILIES WILL COME HERE TO SIX
FLAGS GREAT ADVENTURE FOR
EXTREME EXCITEMENT.
A FEW THINGS TO KEEP IN MIND,
RESERVATIONS ARE REQUIRED, MASKS
ARE MANDATED AND NO STOPPING AT
THE FRONT GATE, TECHNOLOGY
WELCOMES YOU AS IT TAKES YOUR
TEMPERATURE.
IF SUSPECTED A FEVER, THEY'LL
SIT DOWN IN THE COOLING AREA
WHERE THEY SIT DOWN WHERE THEY
TRY AGAIN.
BY THE WAY, VACCINATIONS ARE NOT
REQUIRED.
ONCE INSIDE, YOU CAN START WITH
THE TOUR OF THE SAFARI, THERE
ARE MORE 1200 ANIMALS FROM SIX
CONTINENTS.
THIS USED TO BE A TOUR IN OPEN
AIR TRUCK NOW YOU DO IT IN YOUR
OWN CAR WHERE YOU CAN TAKE OFF
YOUR MASK.
IT'S EASY TO WORK UP AN APPETITE
CANVASSING THE PARK.
MOST OF THE RESTAURANTS OFFER
OUTDOOR SEATING YOU JUST CAN'T
SHARE A TABLE WITH ANOTHER
GROUP.
YOU CAN USE AN APP ON YOUR PHONE
TO ORDER AHEAD.
THANK YOU.
AND KEEP ON GOING.
SIX FLAGS ACROSS THE COUNTRY GOT
MORE THAN 7 MILLION GUESTS IN
2020 EVEN WITH A TEMPORARY
CLOSURE.
YOU CAN BET THE PARKS WILL BE
BUSY THIS SUMMER WITH FAMILIES
LOOKING FOR FUN.
BUT CLEANING CREWS ARE READY.
THE CLEANING PROTOCOLS ARE
DIFFERENT AT ALL SIX FLAGS BUT
HERE THE TRAFFIC LIKE THE JOKER